what's poppin rockstars my name is mt
and loki season one is
over leaving us all doomed back to our
painful
empty mobius-less existences which is
not fun it's been hard without my
favorite mustached man
but not before introducing the mcu's
next major pain
majors kane the next marvel big bad that
we learn about through this forever
bored and alone variant called he who
remains in the loki finale you know the
one kang that beat out all the other
inferior kings in kang of duty war zone
for the mcu entertainment console but if
there's one thing that big daddy kang
taught us is that multiverse pimpin
ain't easy and now that sylvia's caused
that pimp to go limp in that he who
remains is now archangel
in god's kingdom the mad mcu multiverse
is about to bring that kang in the form
of an infinite number of different
versions of king the conqueror all now
watching a piece of that newly freed
multiversal real estate but while many
of us og's of the kang gang
already know all about this time
traveling control freak of a blueberry
there are many of our brothers and
sisters and gender label resistors of
the speculation nation who have no idea
who kang even is or the different
identities that kang has embodied over
his 60 years in the marvel comics
because good god does comic kang
sure love him a good wardrobe change but
fear not my nerd babies i am here to
give you the lowdown
on earthang kang but also all those main
king personas of note and how they could
show up in upcoming mcu phase 4 titles
so without further ado let's get
kangerous
the man who would become kane the
conqueror was originally just some earth
nerd named nathaniel richards from the
year 3000.
and since not much has changed and they
live underwater it's no surprise that
nathaniel richards would decide to copy
the jonas brothers
and build his ass a time machine
specifically to go do hood rat stuff
in ancient egypt and by the way if
you're wondering why kang nathaniel
richards has the same name as mr
fantastic's dad
it's mostly because he was straight up
named after mr fantastic's dad because
that became nathaniel's great great
great great great great
fantastic grandpappy ancestor who was
also a time traveler
go figure nathaniel kang decides to time
travel to the wi-fi list ancient egypt
and use all of his fancy cool future
technology
to completely take egypt over as its
ruler becoming the infamous villain
pharaoh rama tut because that's what
good
time tourists do just take over just uh
egypt why not
actually kang's first ever introduction
to the marvel comics was as
the super secret time traveler rama tut
when he first learned
the fantastic four to fight him in the
past in fantastic four issue number 19.
now out of all of kang's many kang sonas
and variants this is one that we're
definitely going to be seeing in the mcu
very soon
not just because kang's time as rama tut
is such a vital part of nathaniel's
evolution towards becoming
a time traveling conqueror but mostly
because the kang sona of rama tut is
also very much an iconic villain in
marvel comics history having been
introduced near the very start of the
fantastic four comics
this all being said if we're talking
about a marvel villain whose identity is
tied to them being a pharaoh from
ancient egypt the most probable mcu
project that we would see a rama tut
variant
being in is of course chloe zhao's
upcoming eternals film i mean the
eternals movie
is set over the course of thousands of
years with the eternals protecting
humanity throughout
earth's history so i can imagine these
celestial loving brown nosers having an
altercation or two with a big jerk of an
egyptian pharaoh who's not actually
egyptian so i definitely expect to see
jonathan majors rocking
some major roses sandals in a surprise
kang cameo this november in eternals but
thank you so much to honeygain for
sponsoring this video honeygain is an
app that makes you
cash just by keeping it running in the
background and they're not promising to
pay all your bills or anything but it's
enough money to cover small purchases
like your netflix subscription every
month or maybe just buy you and a buddy
some tasty beverages like some kang tang
it's delicious okay here's how it all
works install honey gain on your device
and that's it you're making money just
by sharing your internet connection
and the app doesn't collect any personal
data instead it uses the internet to
gather bits of information from the web
like the best prices on airline tickets
and honey game doesn't have any effect
on your internet experience and doesn't
require
any permissions on your device and
whenever you have twenty dollars
withdraw your money from paypal or
bitcoin and go buy your buddy that
beverage because he's thirsty we all
thirsty and if you want to increase your
earnings refer a friend and get a sweet
little 10
recurring commission of his earnings so
use code new rockstars when signing up
or click the link in the description
down below
and get five dollars added to your
account today but anyways what also
makes a ramatuk cameo within the mcu
extremely likely
is this sphynx within the void from
episode five of loki because kane the
conqueror
has used a whole ass sphinx as a time
machine in the comics before
like that sphinx that we saw in episode
5 could have belonged to a ramitat kang
varied in the past that he who remains
defeated in the gulag
moving on the fantastic four kicked king
nathaniel's butt so hard that he runs
off at his time machine like a little
[ __ ]
only for rama tut to run into another
one of his potential ancestors
victor von doom who inspires him to stop
cosplaying as rama tut and dress up as
the scarlet centurion instead which is
basically just different [ __ ]
same [ __ ] now while the main kang
from the comics didn't spend a whole lot
of time as a scarlet centurion
there does exist an alternate reality
version of kang scarlet centurion
that frequently fought with the squadron
supreme and since the squadron supreme
are basically marvel's variants of dc
comics justice
league i can see marvel studios having a
kang scarlet centurion variant pop up in
universe hopping projects like
multiverse of madness
what if or quantum media fighting his
quadrant supreme nemesis because
everybody knows
that squadron supreme is coming they're
inevitable for the mcu but anyways after
his brief stint as the scarlet centurion
ended in absolute failure
egyptian nathaniel with the sandals
tries to go back to the year 3000 but
accidentally
goes to earth in the year 4 000 instead
of 3000
and finds a bunch of barbaric morons in
a war-torn society
right for the taking so naturally rama
tutkang was like you know what
it's not egypt but i can work with this
and it was that that moment when
nathaniel richards decided to abandon
all sense of fashion completely and
fashioned himself his iconic green and
purple battle suit with the blueberry
face
and conquered the barbaric 40th century
as his first ever conquest
as kang the conqueror and from then on
kang would go on to conquer various eras
of the marvel universe
but during his time as kang he has
inevitably taken on various identities
and spawned countless variants of
himself because of course he did so much
so that there was legit
enough of him to form an
interdimensional council of kang
which is of course what was alluded to
by he who remains in the loki season
finale all those kang is coming together
to work together but you know since
they're all [ __ ] that doesn't really
work out but yeah i'm just going to
quickly list off some of the most
important king sonas that are probably
most likely going to show up
in phase 4 of the mcu starting with iron
lad of the young avengers yes
iron lad is actually king the conqueror
but a 16 year old virgin of nathanael
who tries to reject his future
as king the conqueror by traveling to
the present day to be a hero
like adult king the conqueror tries to
go back in time to try to convince his
younger self to start conquering earlier
and his younger self is like
nah you just show me the highlight reel
of blood destruction and pillaging and
death i want to go be a good guy
and with the mcu clearly setting up the
young avengers with their latest titles
like falcon on the winter soldier and
loki and everything
definitely expect a young iron lag kang
to play a role in quantum mania
alongside scotland's daughter cassie
who of course becomes the young
adventure stature and
a love interest for young kang
iron lad and of course we cannot forget
to talk about immortus one of the most
unique kangs
of all mostly because in the entire
marvel multiverse there is only one
version of a mortise just one like there
is no immortus
variant and mortise is a version of kane
that gets so tired of conquering and
just decides to set up a castle
in the pocket dimension of limbo and
from there he has had run-ins with the
avengers but he's less
aggressive and hateful towards the
avengers and all the other kang variants
he's more
sort of doing things for his own gain
and since loki season 1 director kate
herron revealed that evil remains is
not mcu's immortus despite similarities
in their characters and attire it is
quite likely that we have yet to see
immortus proper
in the mcu and we'll likely see him in
ant-man and the wasp quantomania as
kang's life from his childhood to his
most older self
will probably be explored and don't be
surprised if we end up seeing immortals
actually helping
team ant-man in that movie considering
that immortus has faced off against
variants of himself in the past
and last but certainly not least we have
the kang variant known as
mr griffin the ceo of kang enterprises
with a cube mr griffin is actually
secretly
a kang variant who gets trapped in our
time of the 21st century and can't get
home because for some reason there's
just isn't a time machine around this
was really weird because
there's like a time machine around every
corner where i live it's like a time
machine of dunkin donuts
so he just decides to stay in our time
period and do his conquering
the old-fashioned way through the evil
power of capitalism and plots his
nefarious schemes of conquest while
pretending to be
a nice ceo man never trust a ceo
especially a ceo
that goes into space in a dick rocket
jeff and with the kang logo showing up
on avengers tower in the void
mr griffin has now shot up as the top
most likely buyer of avengers tower that
we hear about
in spider-man homecoming and since
homecoming and far from home
have both hinted out new things coming
for avengers tower i very much
anticipate to see a mr griffin debut
in spider-man no way home but those are
all the kings of note which king variant
are you guys the most excited for you
gotta let me know in the comment section
below my nerd babies because i love
hearing from you which cane do you want
marvel to bring but anyways thank you
guys so much for watching this video be
sure to follow me
mastertainment on twitter and instagram
if you guys want to see me post some
weird [ __ ]
most importantly follow new rockstars
wherever we are especially on youtube
and when you do make sure to hit the
notification bell so you get
notifications whenever we upload
dope [ __ ] which is 24 7. make sure to
hit up new rockstarsmerch.com so you can
get cool shirts like this
black widow shirt and our loki inspired
merch as well some of our stuff is not
going to be there forever so be sure to
go there asap things are getting pruned
but yeah thanks again for watching i'll
see you guys later i love
you goodbye
[Music]
you